supprimer les aides régionales aux
délinquants multirécidivistes laurent
wauquiez n'est pas le premier à évoquer
cette possibilité mais candidat à sa
réélection à la tête de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
il est assurément le plus visible en ce
moment premier problème certaines scènes
régionales sont rendues obligatoires par
la loi
la région ne peut donc pas décider de ne
pas la verser c'est le cas par exemple
des aides à la formation professionnelle
d'autres aides sont facultatives comme
par exemple la gratuité des manuels
scolaires mais la plupart des régions
sinon toutes ont malgré tout pris en
charge les manuels des lycéens
peut-on priver de cette aide d'un élève
délinquants le problème c'est qu'ici il
ne serait pas cohérent d'exclure un
élève délinquants de la gratuité des
manuels scolaires car l'objectif de
cette gratuité est bien c'est de lutter
contre les exclusions sociales en
favorisant l'apprentissage on en a la
preuve le maire de béziers avait voulu à
l'époque subordonner les aides de la
ville aux familles à l'attitude
citoyenne de leurs enfants
l'injustice a condamné cette décision au
motif que s'est elle inquiétée des aides
de secours ont pour objet de secourir
les personnes en détresse et non pas de
rapports sinon aucun rapport avec
l'attitude citoyenne de la personne mais
ce n'est pas tout comment un président
de région peut-il savoir quand je
n'étais linquan et en plus multi
récidiviste actuellement la région n'a
pas accès aux casiers des bénéficiaires
des aides régionales il faudrait donc
modifier la loi
et puis enfin les régions n'ont pas de
compétences en matière de répression
pénale tout cela ne veut pas dire qu'il
faudrait refermer le débat lancé par
laurent wauquiez non cela veut
simplement dire que ce débat il ne doit
pas avoir lieu à une échelle régionale
mais nationale